the latest cbs news battleground tracker
poll
shows former vice president joe biden is
leading president trump by
six points in pennsylvania and wisconsin
two of the states that swung the last
presidential election to mr trump
the presumptive democratic nominee is
set to announce his running mate
any day now ahead of the party's
convention that begins
one week from today ed o'keefe is
covering campaign 2020.
even on a bike ride at his vacation home
in rehoboth beach delaware the former
vice president couldn't escape the
question
everyone wants answered mr vice
president have you picked the running
mate yet
yeah you have who is it who is it
joking aside biden is expected to
announce his vp pick
in the coming days most of the women
under consideration haven't been seen in
public recently
but one of them former obama national
security adviser susan rice
was spotted playing tennis with her
husband on sunday
ambassador have you been interviewed by
vice president biden
happy sunday meetings hope you're having
a good one cbs news has learned that
biden has met face to face with at least
one of the contenders
michigan governor gretchen whitmer flew
to delaware last sunday to meet with him
the 48-year-old first term governor
gained national attention
for her strict stay-at-home order during
the pandemic
in an interview with cbs sunday morning
jill biden says
she's weighed in on the big choice we've
talked about
the different women candidates but it's
got to be joe's decision
who he feels most comfortable with
who shares his values and that's what
he's always said that
he and barack had let's remember the
potential history here only two other
women
have been picked to run for vice
president on a major party ticket and
biden's choice of course
could be the first woman of color chosen
for the role
we've also learned this morning a little
bit more about what democrats are
planning for their convention that
begins in a week
among the party leaders there will also
be regular americans invited to speak
including a pennsylvania farmer who
voted for the president four years ago
and says he won't do so again this year
because he disagrees with his trade
policies michelle
keeping it close to the best he is got
to make a decision soon ed thank you so
much